[Music]
I'm a first amendment absolutist I
believe in only two things completely
the First Amendment and boobs joining me
today is the host of out kick the
coverage on Fox Sports Radio and a man
who has never never been let down by
boobs Clay Travis welcome to the rubric
Laurie I'm happy yeah that's the best
introduction I've had in a long time
that is well that is your introduction I
knew there was only one way I could do
it and it was gonna have to be about
boobs you like boobs I do in the First
Amendment both in fact when I showed up
today at your place I had on my boobs
and First Amendment shirt that we sold a
lot of at the eye appearance on CNN and
I'd like to say that it was some grand
viral attempt to create a stir and it's
not like I'm a beyond or above that but
no I I've been saying that for years
writing it saying it's not years and st.
the men say it the women and I certainly
didn't think it was going to turn into
the viral sensation that it did yeah but
it did turn into viral yeah I saw you
were trending on Twitter that's like
basically the highest compliment you can
get these days the outrage over it so in
a second we're gonna show some of Brooke
Baldwin's reaction when you said it
truly did you did you have no sense that
anything was gay because I saw a lot of
you see what he did there you see he no
I said it on headline news the day
before
yeah to a female anchor I have said it
on my radio show probably a hundred
times I've written it in my columns yeah
it was it's such like it kind of a words
that I'm used to saying that I just went
to it because it's part of a natural
argument there and I once I saw like
remember when I'm doing that show and
you'll know this but I think a lot of
people listening and viewing will not
when you are I was doing that from my
home studio so I can stare like I'm
staring at you right now I can see how
you react to everything that I say but
in my home studio I have no monitor so I
don't even know who the other person is
that I'm talking with I can just hear
their voices and I can't see her facial
reactions at all but as soon as she
reacted I knew what she was doing I knew
there was somebody in her ear saying
like oh this is Trump's America you got
to go after this guy clay Travis he's a
misogynist he's a boar you know you've
got him you've got to put him in his
place
and so what I do for better or worse is
when people want me to like hit reverse
and back up and apologize
I put the you know pedal to the metal
and go forward full steam so I doubled
down I tripled down I may have even
quadrupled down so once that happened I
knew what she was trying to do yeah I
was her producer in her ear saying you
got to stand up on behalf of all women
or whatever you know some some clearly
artificial reaction on her part I think
yeah because it really kind of torpedoed
the entire segment
I mean professional from her yeah I will
the other guests then sort of bought in
on it too he attends and then I think
you or at least one of your fans
why on earth some of his old tweets
where he said so I mean the idea that
that liking boobs has become
misogynistic yes
shows you how bananas the whole debate
has gone well not only that I mean it's
not like women are surprised at men like
boobs right big business victorious
women Ellie exactly cosmetic surgery the
Victoria's Secret has revolutionized the
bra industry in the last 30 years like
golf clubs right new technology that
comes out so women understand that boobs
are attractive to men right so it's not
like it was somehow like this crazy
thing to say and then she was like I
can't believe you would say that to a
woman I'm like I would say it to a man I
for better or worse here in large
extreme and my wife would say this too I
talked the same to men and women and so
to me expecting that I would change the
way I'm gonna speak because a woman is
interviewing me I would talk to her that
if you were a woman right now I'd be
talking to you the same way that sexism
yo I try to treat everybody the exact
same what may not be great play drive is
an [ __ ] but he's equally an [ __ ]
to everybody if you want to criticize me
for that right you're so right that's
what I used to say about gay marriage
it's like you gotta let people be equal
so that you can treat them as shitty as
everybody else if they don't have to be
as miserable as miserable as my wife
yeah yeah they deserved that right they
absolutely do alright so real quick
we're gonna show just the 45 second or
so reaction from Brooke and we're not
gonna do an hour we can't do it out but
we're not gonna but let's just watch
that real quick and I just want to make
sure I'm hearing you correctly oo
because as a woman I'm I said boobs
I believe completely in the First
Amendment and in boobs those are the
only two things I believe 100% in in
this country and by the way Jamel has
did you notice that he went straight to
that yeah you're absolutely right I live
on national television and with a female
host I say all the time because it's
true and that's what I do because I like
boobs and the First Amendment which is
exactly what I said listen listen Brooke
I think that speaks for itself so the
fake outrage that's the interesting
thing to me and you already hit on this
a little bit but she most likely had
somebody in her ear saying you've got to
stand up for women and all that stuff
do you realize what was happening while
it was happening
again the challenges I don't see the
reaction yeah I knew you know when she
comes back to me and says it spells out
boobs
yeah like again I had the opportunity to
back up but at that point in time I
meant what I said it's not like I'm
gonna say oh I apologize let me throw
myself into the fetal position and beg
for the forgiveness of left and wing
America who's perpetually outraged yeah
and in fact I knew that I was in for a
battle and I I've said this before but I
kind of like being in the center of
media storms you know I feel like
there's a certain peace that comes over
you when you're in the middle of like
and in the arena literally fighting in
the moment yeah I want I reminds me when
I was a kid
Brer Rabbit you know there were a story
like don't throw me in the briar patch
yeah I love being in the briar patch or
you hear pigs like don't get in the mud
with the pig like he likes being in the
mud
I like wallowing around in the mud so I
knew as soon as she cut the interview
short that it was gonna be a viral
sensation right and I've been in enough
in these situations where people choose
sides automatically and they like Oh
clay Travis is awesome Oh Clay Travis
sucks Bravo for CNN CNN sucks I know how
you know sort of bipolar the reaction is
gonna be for lack of a better term and
so I immediately got on Twitter and
tweet it out ESPN just I mean sorry CNN
couldn't just cut my interview short
because I said I love the First
Amendment and boobs I don't remember
what the exact tweet I said was but I
sent that and then I immediately got on
the benefits of having all these media
apparatus ready I immediately got on
periscope and Facebook Alive and told my
side of the story and took it to the
next level and said oh by the way we're
gonna sell First Amendment in boobs
t-shirt
and we're gonna donate the proceeds to
breast cancer awareness which just
throws everybody into an uproar right
because and and and then I think I was a
head of the media storm and I knew the
media storm was gonna come and at that
point in time you can't check your phone
you can't even check Twitter it's just
an onslaught but what I did love was I
got a call from CNN asking me to come on
Monday right and so then I tweeted like
CNN's not outraged you know they want me
to come on Monday as well they left me a
voicemail so I played that voicemail the
next day CNN denies that they left me a
voicemail says that there's no truth to
it and then late that night I get a text
message saying hey this is not gonna
work but I will say this then I've told
this story maybe once or twice but my
wife is downstairs cuz I do everything
out of my out of my house and she and
right before then I've been saying okay
I've got to do this one more interview
it's been a busy week because that had
been a really busy week for us it was
Friday
and I was like we'll be done in the
afternoon we'll chill we'll go out we'll
take the boys out for pizza just have a
chill night yeah and and it's 2:30 in
the afternoon my time whatever it is I
do that hit and my wife just texts me
from downstairs never good when you get
texted by your wife even bother walking
upstairs do I need to put the house on
the market because my wife here my
wife's fear and I think there's probably
a lot of spouses who have lived through
this is that when you're in this middle
of this perpetual outrage machine at
some point the mob wins yeah right and
my argument is I'm gonna fight the mob
for the rest of my wife I like it I
enjoy it I think they're wrong and I'm
right
mm-hmm but I think her fear is at some
point they're gonna come for you and
they're gonna scalp you and they're
gonna win a fight yeah and she when she
saw that she was like this is gonna be
bad for you they're gonna tight cash to
you as a sexist they're gonna say you
hate women and my argument was I know
that's not true
and accusations are insults a levied
against me that I know aren't true if
you want to say I'm racist sexist
misogynistic whatever else and call me
whatever you want
to me I've called myself worse you know
and I probably get called worse by the
people that did I live with how did that
conversation go with your wife because
that's serious I mean that's very stuff
I get it I understand what that means
look she is prepared we watched and I
had a read to go back and read because
Howard Stern's an idol mine so you need
to read what his wife went through
imagine what what life was like for him
and
early 90s to me when you're trying to be
as honest as you possibly can people say
they want honesty but a lot of times
they don't really want they want the
fluff they want the aurait sysm is bad
Oh sexism is bad they don't want you to
actually dive into the nitty-gritty of
details and figure out what the facts
are of a situation and I've always said
that maybe this came to me in law school
I remember a criminal law professor I
had who said there are three things that
matter about every case the facts the
facts and the facts and for what we do I
always find that there's so few people
they don't actually look at the facts
the original documents of a story look
at the basis for what they're basing
their opinion on and in this world that
we live in now everybody's decided what
they believe and a story happens and
everybody just uses it as an excuse to
justify whatever they already believe
facts be damned and I feel like I'm in
the rarity you're in the rarity you sit
back and say okay let's actually look at
the details here and figure out what the
story is before we decide whether it
fits our worldview or not yeah and
what's interesting I think for guys like
us and I think that we are that these
ideas at least are becoming the silent
majority is that in our cases we both
are two-time Obama voters I was a
progressive Gore's presidential campaign
right so we've done that like it's not
you know because after this what it
would interested me so much wasn't just
wasn't just okay the boobs comment yeah
it is what it is you know what I mean
but it's it's the reaction after the
manufacturing of the of CNN the the PR
team inviting you on then Brooke saying
no he's banned forever but just this
machine versus the guy who was invited
on says a line that he always says but
then you you took the power back because
you're like I'll periscope the truth
I'll play the voicemail but then you
also have to deal with all the family
[ __ ] and all that and it just it shows
you there's a certain David versus
Goliath thing that I just love about it
it's totally true and look when I also
went back if you watch that clip the
other guy who was on there claims that
he's offended by what I said has sent
all sorts of more ridiculous tweets and
my audience that's the other good that's
a beautiful thing that is - yeah the
people who support us love us yeah right
and and that is that is
very gratifying because when you're in
the war all the time when you're in the
battle every day it's good to know
there's some people who have your back
yeah and they may not be able to have
your back in the same public leg that
you or I can because this is what we do
for a living but there's so many people
out there working at companies that
serious jobs that were worried about
being out there in the arena fighting
because they got to protect their family
they got to make the mortgage payment
they got to do everything else but I
think it's it's gratifying to see them
saying hey we support you here but yeah
they went back I didn't do it they went
back and looked through all of his
tweets and started popping me with look
at what this guy said and then they go
back and find the same thing with Brooke
Baldwin Don lemons on there talking
about how great Kathy Griffin's Rack is
on with her he's coming on to show his
nipples on you know New Year's Eve she
doesn't react at all to that nipple net
Kathy Griffin says nipple like six or
seven times no hair like that's the
point I nobody came to me from a
journalistic perspective and I'm far
from a journalist in a grand scheme
right I have an opinion in but when you
have it the discussion going on to me
where she made the biggest error is and
it was great for me because it went
viral millions of people saw it we sold
you know lots of shirts we were asked a
lot of money for breast cancer awareness
it was all positive for me but to me
where she failed is she had an
opportunity to have a serious discussion
about a substantive issue and when you
react to a word which in no way needed
to be reacted to I was on to the next
argument right it was just part and
parcel of my larger argument she allowed
that segment to be derailed in a way
that it didn't need to be
but isn't that so consistent with
everything that this set of people is
doing these days like if she would have
just let it slide or even just it could
have been a three-second maybe that was
the wrong word kind of thing and then
moved on then if this wouldn't have all
happened but what happened after the
truth is clay Travis is bigger so as you
said here the fact remains this all
worked to your advantage because you
like being in the fight you know how to
do it and all that but what does that
tell you about just the general state of
media but also sort of what's happening
with the left that they they so go over
the top that they end up strengthening
all I mean this is what they're doing
with whatever the alt-right is or the
white promises these days are all that
it's like you keep building them yeah
because you you need them in a bizarre
way yeah
they need it and they also are devouring
it's like a snake eating its own tail
right the left devours itself it seems
to me is what is going on here but you
create all of these mountains of oh
there look there have always been racist
people like it I go back in time and say
it's amazing to me that in 2017 while
we're talking the stock market is at an
all-time high unemployment is at an
all-time low
the per-capita income of the average
household has never been higher on an
inflation-adjusted basis in the history
of our nation those are three really
magnificently big facts that should mean
that people in the country are pretty
happy this should be like the late
nineties right like the Bill Clinton was
in charge getting [ __ ] from interns
before like you know I wish he hadn't
gotten a [ __ ] from an intern but
stock markets rolling like it's kind of
good he hasn't taken us to war I didn't
mind the it was I was in GW at the time
at George Washington in an undergrad and
one of the guys that I knew this is a
it's really funny it was even funnier in
social media era but he had been hooking
up with Monica Lewinsky
so it's funny like he's think about the
president's election and who he's having
an affair with she's also sleeping
around that same time maybe not the
exact time but with a random college guy
right
at least JFK was having an affair with
Marilyn Monroe right probably
we're probably gonna find out a lot more
and then there's cuz they're gonna drop
the maybe it maybe that was the reason
he got assassinated but but like at
least he was like with the most famous
woman in the world at the time that's
kind of what you would want to resident
to have an affair with right Bill
Clinton's having an affair with a random
girl who's living in her mom's apartment
in in Watergate which maybe speaks to
Bill Clinton's ability to connect with
everybody who speaks to Hillary Clinton
all sorts of things that could hit yeah
but but to me this is actually a really
good time in the country and so I just
don't buy into this the world of fear
and I think there's so many people out
there that are wrapped up and
encapsulated by their fears every single
day right they're afraid that they're
gonna be that there is violence lurking
everywhere and I know murder is up in
the last couple of years and everything
else but I just think it's a pretty good
time to be in America today and of all
the times that I've been in the
tree-like this is the least racist this
is the least sexist right I mean things
are moving in the right direction and I
feel like the left wing is making it
such that people who might be natural
allies like you were I war no no on like
out there fighting for things
progressive ideals they're making me
take a step back and be like I don't
want to be on this person's side yeah
you know if you're not if you're banning
To Kill a Mockingbird because the n-word
is in it I don't want to be on your side
like that's not a battle that I want to
fight on your behalf and I feel like
they're alienating a lot of
middle-of-the-road people not just
conservatives but lots of
middle-of-the-road people I consider
myself to be a very middle-of-the-road
guy yeah and the left wing is totally
turned me off so I completely agree
obviously and I consider myself to be
pretty Center and right now I have every
week I have someone in here that I agree
with on some stuff and disagree with on
some other stuff I've literally never
sat across from someone that I agree
with whatever really right yeah we must
be the Aristotle and Plato of our time
yeah I guess so you you mentioned right
before we started your your wake up
because as we said you worked on the
gore campaign you voted for Obama twice
and all that so donate money to John
Kerry there you go to try to help get
elected a black guy running for the
Senate in Tennessee what you want to
talk about us is Sisyphean task he lost
a bob Corker back in I think was oh six
so I'm guessing he did it not because of
his the color of his skin but before any
legs I thought you'd be a better
candidate then then bob Corker was yeah
and look and so yeah like I worked in
democratic politics for three years
while I was in college I was on the hill
with Nashville's congressman I'm born
and raised in Nashville Tennessee and
and so I did all of those things I
worked I got fired off of a the campaign
to replace this guy Bob Clement by Jim
Cooper because I wrecked his wife's
Volvo this is actually a pretty funny
story after my first year
that's some serious campaigning after my
first year of law school I was and madly
in love with my my girlfriend then
girlfriend now wife and she went off to
college she decided she didn't wanna be
a lawyer we met in law school and she
went to New York for the summer to dance
with Alvin Ailey talented like went on
to be a Titans cheerleader like that's
where the out kicked the coverage phrase
okay right I ended up with a girl a lot
better than I deserve like a lot of
people probably were watching and
listening right now
and and so the the cut that he wasn't a
congressman yet he was a former
congressman who had lost the Senate race
to Fred Thompson he was running for the
nashville seat jim cooper and so he had
a health scare I actually had colon
cancer they found like a colon polyp or
whatever it is and he had to have
surgery and so he was off the campaign
trail
I was his body man I went everywhere
that he went so that was a cool kind of
ground-floor introduction to politics
and so when he went away he was gonna be
off the trail for a week I decided to
fly to New York City to go surprise my
girlfriend now wife spend the weekend
with her hanging out in New York City
middle of a horrible heat wave she was
living in this dingy like you know like
awful like literally like like not much
bigger than this table exactly like a
lot of people who are young and in
college and her in New York City for the
summer so we're up there hanging out and
I flew into Islip because Southwest
Airlines from Nashville was so much
cheaper than flying into LaGuardia or
JFK woulda been I know yeah so I flew
into Iceland you had to take the Long
Island Rail Road into the city no I are
right and so I'm going back on Sunday
and that Sunday they had a massive I
think it was like a like a gas leak and
they shut down the LIRR so you couldn't
get to Iceland unless you had I don't
know what a cab cost back then like $200
there's might been two hundred thousand
dollars and so I had to take that they
turned everybody around went back I
didn't get back in time he shows up
several days early to start campaigning
and at the same time I'd also just
wrecked his wife's car his wife's Volvo
and so they fired me so that was the end
of my political career I was 23 and and
I was but I was working on a Democratic
campaign he's still a friend of mine but
yeah so it wasn't just that I voted
Democratic it was like I literally gave
what I think is almost the most
sacrosanct of everything my labor
yeah well elected it's so funny because
I said to you Brett before we start I
was like I when I started I wanted to do
what you do I mean I wanted to be like a
sports center anchor we're talking
sports all day now I'm talking politics
all day it's like you were doing more
political stuff now you're talking
sports but you're talking politics all
the time they named intersected I'm sure
we're
yes so inescapable yeah let's get to
that because I talked about it a bunch
with Whitlock and Jason Joaquin yeah
I've really crystallized it for me
because I do I am starting to see this
as a major danger to society I agree
with you on the hopeful in this part
right now I agree there's so much
fertile ground for ideas even the people
who have ideas that are completely
against my 180 fight for them and guess
what they are fighting for them I think
they're the wrong ideas but as long as
we're not killing each other yes I think
this this argument a marketplace of
ideas is good for America I'm all about
that what I do think is actually
dangerous though is the inability right
now for us to escape the fight which is
why I try to take weekends off social
media and all that stuff so but but for
you a guy that's in sports sports to me
is when sports done right is the most
beautiful thing ever based in
competition and no it doesn't matter
where you're from or what religion you
are it's the it's beautiful beyond just
the - hearted and the janitor can get
together and talk as equals about sports
in a way that I don't think happens in
any other part of American life today
absolutely or anytime if you just go
play pick-up basketball you don't care
what color anyways can they play yes and
they play that's it but this this thing
where they've become so intertwined now
for you you like both so I get it's
probably pretty cool for you but do you
think at a societal level that there's
something kind of dangerous going on
here yeah I can I think in general
because I think that what I talked about
before is sports as a connective tissue
that I think binds many people in this
country who would otherwise have nothing
else in common
and I speak from somebody's perspective
who is from the south right I grew up in
Nashville SEC football if you are in the
11 state football region the 11 state
SEC teams how are in is the tie that
binds the the first book that I wrote
Dixieland delight was about why people
love SEC football so much and it unites
across racial grounds at least in my
generation obviously it was a big part
of why the South in general got
integrated because if you believe the
stories about Bear Bryant he decided you
know what we got to have some black guys
on the team because USC came down to
Alabama and kicked their ass with Sam
BAM Cunningham and the famous line even
though it may not be a hundred percent
true is that in 60 minutes
Sam Cunningham did more to integrate the
south than anybody else had done in 200
years because people love football so
much they said wait
got to be better and we gotta have the
best people regardless of where they're
from regardless of their color
regardless of their religion anything
else yeah and so I think what's happened
is you go from from there to you know
the Michael Sam the Caitlyn Jenner the
Colin Kaepernick area and we can talk
about all those but those are all to me
things that take us outside of the field
of competition mm-hmm
and Michael Sam is a fascinating one
because I think the NFL is the ultimate
meritocracy doesn't matter where you're
from doesn't matter whether maybe you
can even read write if you can I'm sure
actually on cases yeah if you can get on
the football field and make it more
likely that a team is going to win then
a team will find a place for you and I
think starting with Michael Sam a lot of
people in sports when they showed him
kissing his boyfriend and like I'm a
pro-gay marriage guy right like I am
people always say like I'm pro-choice I
am you know anti the death penalty like
I could run through all my list right
yeah we should probably we'll do that
yeah but you know like things that I
don't think necessarily would you be
like the Politico said Oak Lake Travis
is a hero at all right I don't know what
that means but I'm like are that are
there tons of people who are pro-choice
out there in the alt right right are
there tons of people who voted for
Barack Obama and all right I mean I
think it's a funny kind of creation of a
media falsehood there but second I saw
that headline I do want to talk about
that article for a second but the second
I saw the headline without even reading
it I knew I was like I know exactly what
they're doing and here we go but let's
pause on that for a second yeah and so I
saw it Michael Sam I said what I saw
immediately was this is not similar to
Jackie Robinson okay because Jackie
Robinson could not escape his race
moreover everybody by looking at him
knew what his race was yeah Michael Sam
more power to him for being gay and
being comfortable coming out I hope he's
having a happy life but the NFL fan
doesn't care about Michael Sam being gay
mm-hmm unless Michael Sam is a great
football player moreover the average NFL
fan doesn't care about Michael Sam at
all yeah if you cover football you cover
guys who make the team much more likely
to win if you're just a distraction in
terms of your not making the team more
likely to win then nobody's gonna cover
you so but is there an inherent problem
with that though at some level that if
these guys if no one is out younger then
the it's incumbent on that someone's got
to do it first right and it's like on
some level should it be the star of
stars who's gonna potentially then
create all sorts of problems for the
team and all that media's up or should
it be the guy that might be about to be
cut and then he doesn't want to do it so
there's like a little bit certainly as a
story but I think the way it was covered
it was covered as if people really cared
right if you were a great defensive end
who had 20 sacks a year then the profile
pieces on Michael Sam I think would have
made sense the fact that he decided that
he wanted to go public with the fact
that he was gay I think a lot of fans
started to say okay you know I feel like
I'm watching the NFL to see whether or
not my team's gonna win not to make a
societal statement and look I don't
think people who disagree with gay
marriage are awful human beings there
are a lot of people in my state who
don't believe that people should be able
to get married if they're gay I disagree
with them but I don't think they're
horrible you know racist bigoted awful
human beings you know I've grew up in a
Southern Baptist Church the vast
majority of people who went to my
Southern Baptist Church probably would
have that belief right yeah I don't
think they're awful human beings I know
I'm pretty well you know what you can do
is talk to them yeah sway them that
they're wrong in the marketplace of
ideas I know instead of brick and rock
that's immediately attacking them right
and so but to me that I opening moment
for me was Mizzou and the University of
Missouri for people who don't know it
this was like kind of everything that I
care about coming together SEC football
I remember being on the airplane flying
back from LA where I was working with
Fox Sports and my Twitter feed blows up
and there's all these people out there
talking about the fact that Missouri's
football team has said they are not
gonna play unless the demands of this
guy who are hunger striking and the
other black lives matter activists are
agreed to and everybody on Twitter is
amazing just about everybody is saying
so brave of the Missouri football team
so brave of Gary Pinkle to support them
this is a massive moment in the world of
sports we're seeing the power of
athletes raising their voice and my
first thought was okay oh that's fine
what's being protested mm-hmm you know
like I understand like I've been on a
college campus I've been in Missouri
I've talked to those kids there it
doesn't seem like a fundamentally racist
place to me they had a gay black student
body president they had embraced Michael
Sam it doesn't seem like a school that
has an inclusiveness or diversity
problem
okay what are the issues three things
that brought about this protest one the
student body president allegedly when
his off-campus somebody yelled a racial
slur to him from a red truck no idea who
it was
yeah may have happened sucks could
happen no witnesses we don't even know
if it happened but yeah I went to GW
right I went to school Washington DC
when I was on college campus if I had
gone to the the president of the student
body at the time and I'd said hey when I
was walking off campus somebody came by
and I've got a couple of my Jewish
friends and somebody yelled anti-semitic
slur on us you need to do something
about it you'd be like that's life you
know like you're in a big city who are
not always gonna be nice to you you know
I wish that nobody was anti-semitic in
this entire city of Washington DC
probably people who hate Jewish people
gay people black people white people
like right there's there's a lot of hate
that exists in the world when you're off
campus that's not my responsibility so
that was one and you just can't manage
all that stuff I mean that's the other
piece you just can't even yeah you can't
manage humanity won't open the idea that
you should go talk to the president of
the school because somebody allegedly
said something mean to you when you were
off campus like all of the things that
the president of the university has
going on yeah
I've been arguing for a while that we
need instead of like all these
inclusiveness ideas everything else
there should also be a counter example
here where the person who makes the most
ridiculous protest has to walk around
with a poster board that says I'm a
gigantic [ __ ] yeah all over campus so
everybody can know like you had the
dumbest thing to complain about on
campus this week well you know the
women's March people like those [ __ ]
hey writer you probably just get a [ __ ]
no doubt you can just walk around in a
[ __ ] ad and that's ideal so that was
one of the things the other one was a
poop swastika yeah and this is just a
funny in a creation in and of itself
because we don't know like I said before
if I had shown up here and somebody had
shown up and they had been like clay
Travis I'm a huge fan of yours and they
had handed me a portrait of me done in
poop I wouldn't be like oh my god this
is an endorsement of me that's a
psychotic thing to do right yeah so we
don't know like when I hear poop
swastika I actually think that's
probably somebody who's not a huge fan
of the swastika and or how crazy would
you have to be to use your own feces to
make a poop swastika right so this is a
mental hell
issue more than anything probably and we
don't know who did it right so that's
really the issue their rights because
virtue signaling has has hit that
fevered pitch to the point that people
are we know that a lot of this stuff is
hoax yeah I mean we simply know happens
every day so it could have been anybody
could have been a Jewish guy who didn't
know a Jewish girl could have been a
black person who's in the protests that
did it right there mental health issues
the third one was somebody walking
through campus who was not a student
said a racial slur they shut down the
University of Missouri over these three
things the football team said they
weren't in a play and so I drove into
all these details I wrote about it and I
wrote about it I covered it pretty
aggressively and I was stunned that I
was the only person in the world of
sports media who was approaching the
story of the Missouri protests by
actually looking at the facts and saying
you know what I don't think that these
activists on campus who want the
university president to stand up on a
table in the university cafeteria and
denounce his white privilege is really
like when you looked at the list of the
demands that they made and yet these
protesters were covered in such a
positive way that the president the
university was forced to resign and the
overall Chancellor of the University of
Missouri was forced out and since then
enrollment has dropped thirty five
percent the university in many ways has
almost died well that was just a couple
of years ago and and to me that was the
first moment for me of really kind of
diving into a media story because it was
in my wheelhouse it was SEC football it
was a Southern University that I was
familiar with it was sports and it was
you know political protest and I said my
god there was no basis in reality for
this what should have happened is the
media should have looked at this pointed
out how illegitimate it was that Gary
pinkles response was actually rooted in
cowardice not bravery that the football
team's decision not to play was rooted
not in an understanding of a other
legitimate protest but just kind of like
a viral form of stupidity mm-hmm I was
the only person taking it and since then
it was like all of a sudden I pulled you
know like the world was like I like
taking the pill in the matrix right like
I've used you take the red pill and
suddenly you start to realize how much
that surrounds you is
[ __ ] and that was the first story where
I really noticed it how quickly did the
rest disintegrate for you because I've
noticed with people and I actually had a
girl on here who you'd probably really
dig her name's Candice Owens her yeah
Twitter's red pill black and yes that's
her YouTube thing and basically she was
a lefty or her whole life and she's in
her late 20s now basically came out as a
black conservative did a really funny
video coming out to her parents as a
conservative basically what she said is
once once she saw it it crumbled really
quick yeah for me because I try to be so
measured with everything it took a
little while like it was people watched
it happened to me over the course of a
couple years cuz I kept trying I kept
going this can't be this camp it can't
be as bad as I think it is I think
people have seen me evolve yes I'll get
people now who say like oh I used to
listen to your show and you wouldn't
ever be involved in stories like these
and to me what I kind of found was if
I'm not saying it there's not anybody
saying it right that's still what's kind
of remarkable about what I do in the
world of sports is I look at facts and I
talk about facts and almost nobody else
is doing it and so I was kind of a
gradual thing I could point to that
you're the Caitlyn Jenner decision I was
like it seemed to me ESPN I still
believe gave her that award so they
could get an exclusive with Diane Sawyer
they put it on ABC I'm like you know
what I mean I understand the purpose of
heroism I'm one of my family members as
trans like if it makes you happy or do
it mmm but I don't think that to me
bravery requires risk of life or liberty
and I don't think that Caitlyn Jenner
risked either and so the idea that she
was incredibly heroic I didn't
necessarily buy into well she was also
an athlete thirty years ago or whatever
40 years ago basically right like when I
see somebody when I see her dashing on
the front row at the ESPYs I'm like this
is a total ratings ploy
yes pians full of [ __ ] in the way that
they're talking about this and then is
this kind of progress that Colin
Kaepernick thing but before the Colin
Kaepernick thing happened we had the
Ryan Lochte story mm-hmm and to me and
in a Peyton Manning story the Peyton
Manning moved a trainer 20 years ago and
suddenly he becomes an incredible
example of white privilege and you go
back and look at it and the woman who
accused him was out to lunch like she
was crazy she was calling people at all
hours of the night she wasn't a reliable
witness and
example I use is we're in this weird
place where if a minority says something
happen or a woman says something happen
you have to believe them or else you are
racist or sexist let's not just believe
you have to bow to it forever
and so my argument is I like to go back
to kill mockingbird which now is getting
banned in the state of Mississippi
because of you know it's - it's an
insanity or a were like a book-burning
air almost it seems but it's a kill
mockingbird Atticus Finch puts Mayella
Ewell on the witness stand and he
aggressively questions whether or not
she was raped and as by virtue of that
aggressive questioning we find out that
she made up the allegation that she was
raped by a black man Tom Robinson the
jury still convicts him because that's
the broken system love southern
jurisprudence in a pre Civil Rights era
but it's a powerful moment because
that's why we have an adversarial system
you don't automatically assume that
somebody is telling the truth because of
their race or because of their gender
and we have so swung I believe from an
era where a black guy's automatically
guilty in the south because he's black
to a black guys telling the truth
because he's a black guy or a woman's
not telling the truth because she's a
woman - a woman's telling the truth
because she's a woman I think you have
to look and this is a crazy I can't
believe I have to say this nah but I
think you have to look at the facts of
every individual case I think that rape
happens I think it's awful but that
doesn't mean that I think every time a
woman says she was raped it's true I
think that racism is awful it shouldn't
happen but that doesn't mean that every
time somebody says something racist
happened that you have to believe it
Michael Bennett's case it's
mind-boggling to me that I'm like the
only person who covered Michael Bennett
case and the guy lied about his
treatment by three minority police
officers in Las Vegas and again all
these red pill moments the Ryan Lochte
the Peyton Manning the Michael Bennett
the Missouri the Bennett thing one is
particularly so because because the
story did the second it all came out
your story just disappeared yes the
media didn't cover it what what what
just happened and and I I have what I
would say like Hemingway said you know
writer has to have a natural [ __ ]
detector right yeah and and also that
you know you see like the iceberg but
you don't see everything underneath the
iceberg well maybe it's the legal
foundation legal training also my
fascination with
stories but I feel like I can see a
story and believe whether or not it's
likely to be true based on the way it's
told and that's because I think I would
be a good trial attorney right I can sit
down ultimately your storytelling
contest who can tell the more believable
story
Michael Bennett's story on its face when
he put it out did not make sense there
are and since we know like what the Las
Vegas police responding to a real
shooting is like mm-hmm but there was a
report of a shooting in a crowded casino
and Michael Bennett said that as they
arrived for that report of a shooting
they decided to grab him and harass him
and violate his civil rights because he
was a black guy well that didn't make
any sense to me I'm like wait there's a
report of ash active shooter in a casino
mm-hmm and these cops who were arriving
on the scene with that information make
the decision to suddenly decide to be
racist against Michael Bennett at that
exact moment while they think there may
be thousands of lives in peril and an
active shooting going on they clearly
thought that he was behaving in a
suspicious fashion that's what I think
at the get-go I didn't know at the time
they were two Hispanic and a black guy I
hadn't seen the videos but that's kind
of I say my life kind of changed in a
one way I think when I did a ride around
when I was in law school I did encourage
everybody out there who's listening or
watching now follow a cop for a night
just sit in the car with a cop and see
what they go through and I think you
will have so much more respect for the
difficulty of their job and so I have a
lot of respect for the difficulty of a
police job and so when I was kind of
like going through this process I looked
at it then we had the videos come out
everything else
basically he's proven a wire on video
yeah and nobody covers it sudden
suddenly and then this one also is crazy
to me
we praise athletes for saying things
that are dumb right nobody and the
reason why I keep talking is if you give
somebody a cookie like if I give my kid
a cookie and tell them they did
something good they're gonna keep doing
it even if they're doing something
stupid right like that's what athletes
are like right now and so every time an
athlete speaks out people praising
LeBron James said last year every time
his son leaves the house he worries that
he might get shot by a police officer
and everybody's like so brave of LeBron
James to come out and say this you look
at the day
lebron james his son is five times as
likely to get hit by a train and die as
he is to get shot by a police officer
when he leaves the house if LeBron James
had said every time my son leaves the
house I worry that he's gonna get hit by
a train everybody been like LeBron James
right but people believe fundamental
untruths because nobody actually goes
into the data and looks at it and so all
these athletes and Colin Kaepernick's a
great example Colin Kaepernick drives me
insane the whole call Kaepernick
protests because when he started
protesting he was protesting something
they wanted the government to do which
the government was already doing he said
he was upset by the killing of mine or
innocent minorities by police officers
and he wanted the government to help
make it stop mm-hmm Barack Obama is the
president Loretta Lynch is the Attorney
General they're already aggressively
investigating every one of the Trayvon
Martin of the Michael Michael like all
of Michael Brown and Michael Brown case
all of the stories they're already
investigating so the analogy I use is
Obama could have just thrown Kaepernick
under the bus and been like I'm glad
that he's protesting but you know we're
already doing exactly what he wants us
to do the analogy that I use is
basically Kaepernick walked into
McDonald's took a knee said that he at
11:30 said that he wanted breakfast the
manager McDonald's comes back out said
he's not gonna stand up till he gets
breakfast and says actually we serve
breakfast all day long here already but
you would think that Colin Kaepernick
was Rosa Parks the way the media has
covered him well that's why also it's so
strange to me that people don't hit on
what Jason Whitlock was so succinct
about which is this is all a business at
the end of the day no one is none of
these owners of the teams or the general
managers or any of these things yes
again are there racist people yes
absolutely and we wish they didn't exist
absolutely and we will fight to yes
they're bad ideas
absolutely but at the end of the day if
you own something and your employees are
doing things that are hurting the bottom
line whether even if you're for the
protests if that protest is means that
enough of your fans aren't buying
jerseys aren't showing up to games
you're a businessman you're not a
magical societal you know puppeteer or
something and people don't understand
that and in the analogy that I use I
always try to use analogies because
people understand better if you because
everything has become so charged if you
talk about it in a sports context so
what I say is what would you think if
you had a package coming from UPS or
FedEx and when the guy showed up the UPS
or FedEx package he had on and make
America great again hat and he said hey
hope you vote for Donald Trump be like
man I I don't think it's good for UPS or
FedEx business or you could add a [ __ ]
hat on he could've said hope you
couldn't vote for Hillary Clinton right
right either direction or if he drove
off and that in their car and they've
got a bumper sticker that supports a
political candidate one way or the other
if police officer if you got a pulled
over for speeding and police officer
came up to the window and he said like
hey got you for speeding here's your
ticket oh by the way mitch mcconnell's
and ask don't vote for him right
whatever you're saying right you'd be
like it's not appropriate for somebody
in a police uniform or a military
uniform or a UPS or FedEx or McDonald's
or Walmart to be expressing political
views while they are in uniform on their
job everybody out there be like oh yeah
I agree with that then why do you think
Colin Kaepernick's should be able to do
it
yeah they got especially now in a social
media age players have the ability to
get their political beliefs out to a
larger audience than has ever existed
before people say oh he's a modern-day
ollie oh it's like the 1968 Olympics
Ollie was not an employee boxers are
self-employed by and large he was not
being signing a paid to getting a
paycheck signed by an owner every week
and the the athletes at the Olympics at
the time were amateurs they might been
representing their country but they
weren't representing anything other than
themselves if you think that it makes
sense for an athlete to alienate half of
his audience of the businessman I think
you're crazy people are ripping Jerry
Jones
I think that's pure insanity ultimately
I think it goes back to what we were
talking about before we even went on
most people have no idea how to get paid
today yeah and so I think that there's a
divorce between athletes understanding
that fans ultimately pay their salary
and they pay their salary about watching
their games by going to their games by
being engaged in the overall storylines
and so to me when I saw the Colin
Kaepernick's story I was again it's the
red pill moment like how in the world
are there so many dumb people trying to
cover this story and doing such a poor
job of it
yeah and ironically it's not even that
they're all dumb they're just trying to
manipulate other people for quiet I
think they're I think it's that and I
think there's also a genuine fear that
you're gonna get fired
yeah if you say anything other than
somebody alleging racism is a hero I
mean I think there's a lot of white
people if you want to criticize the
diversity of the sports media there's no
diversity of thought first of all 96% of
people did not vote for Donald Trump you
know the it's almost impossible to find
somebody who admittedly voted for Donald
Trump that writes or talks about sports
and also there's a lot of white guys and
even if you are conservative in your
mindset there aren't that many to begin
with there is a fear that if you go out
and do what I did if you say these
protesting Missouri students who are
predominantly black if you say you think
they're full of [ __ ] well that means
you're racist why you know like I think
people who are full of [ __ ] are full of
[ __ ] regardless of what color they are
and that's why I look at the facts and
you know sometimes I you know there is
the legitimacy behind behind a complaint
I said that I thought Izzy kiyul Elliot
getting suspended was ridiculous did
have anything to do with the fact that
z-coil it's black
had to do with the fact that the NFL I
think had poor evidence to support his
suspension so I go to the real documents
and I look at them and as a result like
somehow I've become the most
controversial person in the world of
sports
[Music]
you
[Music]